joe biden is separating migrant children
from their guardians and putting them
in cages filled to the brim without
social distancing
the white house won't admit it the
president won't remember it
but we've got the receipts and we
shouldn't let anyone forget i'm michael
nolais the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from
old schooled who says if this was the
most
secure election of all time why is there
an
election reform bill going through
congress right now
you know that's a great question that's
a great
you sound like one of those kooky crazy
conspiracy theorists
that question is so good if the election
is so this was absolutely no questions
about it there's been fraud in every
single election
we've ever had and that there has ever
been in world history but
not this one this one it was absolutely
100 perfect
and that's why we need an unprecedented
sweeping historic
election reform bill which is really
just
a massive massive power grab by the left
to upend our elections
kind of makes you wonder doesn't it it's
the kind of question you can ponder over
a lovely glass
of delicious wine which is why i would
highly recommend
first leaf having a first leaf wine club
membership is like being a vip
in the world of wine i can discover top
rated wine i love at an exclusive
discounted cost
with practically zero effort first leaf
is a wine club that sends personalized
selections of wine
from top vineyards around the world
right to your door
every bottle is hand picked by experts
with your exact preferences
and palate in mind no more guesswork or
let downs
unlike other wine clubs first leaf uses
an algorithm
and your feedback to curate future wine
recommendations which means
shipments only get better i've always
been skeptical of wine clubs
i was skeptical of first leaf at first
i've been members of other wine clubs
these guys are great they send you wines
they kind of challenge your palette a
little bit but they're also in tune with
your palette
and then as you rate them they start to
send you new stuff that you're going to
like more and more it's really terrific
discover a new wine like a vip by
becoming a first leaf member joined
today you'll get six bottles of wine for
29.95
and free shipping which is a
ridiculously low price just go to
tryfirstleaf.com
knowles that six bottles of wine for
29.95 and free shipping at
tryfirstleaf.com
slash knowles go check out first leaf
absolute great way to get some delicious
wine today
just a few days ago jen
saki our favorite current white house
press secretary
was asked about certain criticism that
the white house is getting
from former president donald trump
trump was observing that the biden
immigration policy is dishonest
and falling apart before our very eyes
and that donald trump handled the
immigration question
much better because he was at least
forthright about what was going on so he
raised all these points
and gensake was offended at the question
we don't take our advice or counsel from
former president trump on immigration
policy which was
not only inhumane but ineffective
over the last four years we're going to
chart our own path forward and that
includes treating children with humanity
and respect and ensuring they're safe
when they cross our borders
so there's a problem with what she said
it's actually very similar to my
favorite comment from yesterday
where we're told it was the most secure
election we've ever had and also
we are in desperate need of a massive
election reform bill
that doesn't make a lot of sense here
jansaki says that
donald trump's immigration policy was
inhumane and ineffective
but if it was inhumane then
it could not have been ineffective if it
was ineffective it could not have been
inhumane
what was inhumane she's saying well you
know they wouldn't let all the illegal
aliens through and they separated kids
and they
put kids in cages and so it's very
inhumane okay
but therefore it would have to be
effective it has to have some effect if
it's going to be this big change and
it's going to be inhumane
but you say no it was also ineffective
it didn't it didn't work at all it
didn't achieve any of its objectives oh
okay
well then what's the problem what's the
big deal
it was it's the same argument that you
heard from walls
are cruel and awful and we should never
build walls and it's un-american and
also they don't work
oh they don't work then what are you so
worried about
it seems to me you're worried because
they obviously do work
then gensake gets to the real question
which is these people pouring pouring
across the border specifically kids
pouring across the border what's joe
biden going to do are there
any discussions within the white house
about reversing
the policy of allowing all unaccompanied
children into the united states
no not at all so i i guess is the plan
then
to take in and safely and humanely find
a home
for an unlimited number of unaccompanied
children
i think this issue requires us taking a
step back as human beings
and as mothers of which i am one i know
there are many
in the room or many at home these kids
are coming they are fleeing prosecution
they are fleeing difficult circumstances
in their home country
when they come here all we're talking
about here is ensuring that they are
treated
safely they are not trafficked they are
not sent back
uh on a uh unsafe journey uh that's what
we're talking about
the kids are fleeing prosecution like
when they they're tax cheats or
something what do you mean they're
fleeing prostate
what little criminal kids are coming
into work oh she meant persecution okay
that was only
a minor problem with her answer the
question is are you going to let
unlimited numbers of these illegal
foreign children come into the country
and
she doesn't want to say yes because that
will irritate most americans who want
controls on immigration but she doesn't
want to say no
because that will irritate the democrats
radical left-wing base
and also because it doesn't seem
compassionate right now
of course in reality this kind of open
borders policy which creates incentives
for more and more kids to come over it's
actually the opposite of compassion
because the majority of just women and
girls for instance who cross the border
illegally are raped or assaulted on the
journey
so it creates all these awful incentives
it's terrible terrible situation
but in a very limited way it doesn't
seem compassionate okay
gen saki though is very clear
they do not take advice from president
trump on immigration policy
until now until now because their
policy was not working it was creating
all of these problems
and so what is the biden administration
doing now
they're they're now doing exactly what
trump did and you don't need to take my
word for it listen to the mainstream
media even having to admit this new york
times
the number of unaccompanied migrant
children detained along the southern
border
has tripled in the last two weeks to
more than 3250
3250 filling facilities
akin to jails as the biden
administration struggles
to find room for them in shelters
so new york times admitting joe biden is
putting
kids in cages usa today
still sheltering children separated the
by administration rather is still
sheltering children
separated from close family members in
federal facilities for weeks on end
something immigrant advocates and
attorneys that hope the new
administration would resolve by now
they're apparently being separated for
weeks
joe biden putting kids in cages
separating them from their families and
then axios reports
biden administration is allowing the
facilities to operate at
100 capacity to meet the demand of the
huge surge in illegal immigration taking
place on the southern border
the centers were previously allowed to
only operate at 50
capacity to adhere to social distancing
guidelines so we had been told just a
few weeks ago
jen saki said well look we need these
overflow facilities which sort of look
like the cages
that donald trump put the kids in that
actually joe biden
barack obama built all those years ago
but the reason we have to do that is
because
it would be insane to put these kids in
a facility that was more than 50
capacity then they might get the virus
what are you crazy you want us to do
that
now they're saying yeah that's what
we're doing yeah that's exactly what
we're doing
which makes a lot more sense to me
because children are at a very very very
very statistically infinitesimally small
risk from the virus
the biden administration after flailing
and failing in their immigration policy
is now
reverting to the policy of the trump
administration
that was effective and that
kamala harris and members of the biden
administration
referred to as crimes against humanity
we were told by gensake none of this
sort of thing was happening
we have a number of unaccompanied minors
children who are coming into the country
without their families
what we are not doing what the last
administration did
was separate those kids rip them from
the arms of their parents
at the border we are not doing that that
is immoral and that is not the approach
of this administration
uh just a quick update yes we are doing
that
and but now it's moral because we're
doing it and it's not the orange man
if you read the new york times which i
don't recommend but if you do
if you read usa today if you read axios
you will see that what gensake just said
there
is not true maybe it was true then week
or two ago
it's not true now the abide in
administration is doing exactly the same
thing
how many conservatives are there count
myself among them
who have liberal friends and relatives
who were harangued or rather the
relatives harangued all of us
for months and months and years and
years saying how can you support
this evil fascist trump administration
that's separating kids from their
families
and putting them in cages uh
because as jen saki's been saying it's a
difficult situation and the democrats
would do exactly the same thing and the
democrats are doing
exactly the same thing and i just don't
want to hear it anymore
i don't want to hear it unfortunately
this isn't being covered probably this
will only be covered on
conservative podcasts maybe in some of
the conservative
media in the in the established media
but
probably most most left-wingers won't
hear about it so maybe you should tell
your left-wing relatives who have been
bugging you about this for years and
years
some democrats are waking up a little
bit here democrat henry cuellar
democrat representative from texas is
actually going further he's saying yeah
the biden administration is mishandling
this whole migration issue
they are uh they're lying about not just
the
kid not separating the kids from their
parents and not just about putting kids
in cages
they're also lying about the numbers
that are coming in
let's look at the numbers since uh
august of last year the numbers have
been
increasing and especially october
november and december we were hitting
70s
000 uh in january we had 78 000 and this
is again
under the trump administration now
moving into the blind administration
buying
it might have started under trump but
when you're the president
you own the situation whether it's a
success or not a success
success it's gonna own it i think in
february we're gonna get about a hundred
thousand
uh and again i don't care what we call
it but i can tell you this
uh those numbers of people that are
being released
they're purposely withholding that
information they've been told
not to withhold that information i now
know
that they're bringing people from
mcallen over to laredo
processing them in laredo and they're
going to release them in my community
so this is a pretty serious charge
that the federal government right now
the administration
is hiding the numbers so we know we're
getting some numbers out there of
this number of adults coming through
this number of kids this number of
people being released but actually
what henry cuer's saying is they're
hiding
the magnitude the enormity of this issue
reminds us of another democratic
political scandal right now
which would be andy cuomo in new york
whose policies directly
led to the deaths of thousands of
elderly new yorkers and then what did he
do when he realized this
he hid the numbers he hid the numbers
from a federal inquiry
so that's the accusations going on now
we'll get to cuomo in just just a little
bit
but first speaking of
uh security you've got to check out ring
so much is going on at our front door
these days that is one thing that has
not changed it's actually gotten
a much much worse you've got people
coming
who want to deliver food i guess that's
a good thing let them in you know
people who want to deliver clothing and
gifts for my cute little newborn baby
that's good too
sometimes relatives want to visit um
so well it's bet you know it's better to
know who's outside the door
before you open the door we'll just
leave it at that okay ring
will allow you to do that you can see
and speak with whoever is at your door
whether you're in your bedroom
whether you are at the office maybe that
you you are on a beach somewhere
on the other side of the world it's got
motion detection so you'll get notified
even if
the people outside don't ring the door
if someone stops by something's going on
ring is going to let you know also makes
a great housewarming gift which i give
away to my friends
in part because it's not very expensive
so you give a great gift you don't have
to spend a lot of money
helps me feel safe when i'm on the road
sweet little elise is at home
right now get a special offer on the
ring welcome kid at ring.com knowles
comes with rings video doorbell 3 and
chime pro the perfect way to upgrade
your front door and start your ring
experience
ring.com knowles that is ring.com
knowles speaking of difficult
immigration cases meghan markle
megan markel this story has fascinated
the entire world the interview between
meghan markle and prince harry who when
he was occasionally allowed to speak and
oprah winfrey
and some people say this is a frivolous
sort of interview it's not i think it
actually gets at the heart
of the decay of our political system
differences that we have not just
between the united states and the united
kingdom
but differences we have between the old
order the old standards of duty and
responsibility and love of country
and a new culture that's replaced it of
narcissism
and selfishness and pursuing one's
appetites
at infinitum meghan markle
explaining why she had to flee
she had to get out of there because she
you know we talked about her a little
bit yesterday
she was so overwhelmed do you know these
royals they expected her to google the
national anthem of her adopted country
into which royal family she was marrying
you know she is shocking
they wanted her to learn some hymns
before
her massive wedding in the church of
england
which her family her new adopted family
actually runs shocking awful can you
believe that kind of
burden who was she going to turn to to
teach her how to be a royal
her fiance the prince i know i don't
know that's so that'd be outrageous how
could you do that
but she goes further she's alleging
racism
which is sort of the signature crime of
of
liberal modernity there no no other
crime can even come close to the crime
of racism
which is expanding in its its definition
by the day
and even by the hour megan markle
says that the royals did not want to
give archie
or any of her children uh the the title
prince
you know the williams kids would be
called prince and princess but not
harry and megan's kids and this was very
offensive
and do you know some unnamed members of
the royal family
actually raised questions about the skin
color or the skin tone of archie before
he would be born hear the allegations
if they can compare what the experience
that i went through was similar to
what has been shared with us kate was
called weighty katie
waiting to marry william while i imagine
that was really hard and i do
i can't picture what that felt like this
is not the same
and if a member of his family will
comfortably say we've all had to deal
with things that are rude
rude and racist are not the same rude
and racist are not the same
this is true racism
is a type of rudeness
rudeness this kind of you know simple
word here really what she's saying is
adversity
racism is a type of adversity racism and
adversity are not the same thing
because there are many other types of
rudeness and adversity
racism is just one of them but for
markle
and for the entire left
racism race is the
defining feature of life
so you can be rich
you can be famous you can be a hollywood
starlet
you can marry a prince one of the
best-known princes
left in the world you can be accepted
into the royal family
but if you are even slightly
dark if you can in any way claim
membership in a racial victim group
which meghan markle
i guess can she certainly does
then you are oppressed there was a
babylon b headline yesterday saying
meghan markle inspires millions of girls
by by showing them that no matter how
rich
and beautiful and famous you are you
still
can claim to be oppressed that's what
she's doing here and the reason that
this interview totally backfired this
was supposed to be a big pr move
by meghan markle to make herself
likeable and to vilify the british royal
family
and i think it had the opposite effect i
don't think the queen has ever been more
popular in her entire life
and i don't think meghan markle's ever
been more unpopular because she totally
misread the situation
she's so
divorced from the reality of of her
situation
she's so consumed by this frivolous
shallow ridiculous racial grievance
ideology
that she can't recognize her own immense
extraordinary privilege and more than
that
she exemplifies this tendency in
modernity
to want all the privileges and not want
any of the duty to her i mean she's
she's spelling this out in the oprah
interview she thinks
oh my gosh being a princess is great i
get to be rich and famous and wear a
tiara and
live in fancy castles man this sounds
awesome
sign me up oh wait a second i have to do
things
oh i don't have the total liberty to do
whatever i want at any given time of the
day
uh yeah that doesn't sound good harry
divorce your family
do it or do it or else leave all your
friends and family
or else i'm gonna do something horrible
and you better you better listen to me
that that was the takeaway from the
interview and in markle's own perverse
mind in her warped mind
she's the victim but she's not she's not
the victim
even this this claim here that uh it was
a slight by the royal family
that little archie was not going to be
styled to prince
does that really hold up to scrutiny
here's her claim in those months when i
was pregnant
all around this same time
so we have in tandem the conversation of
he won't be
given security it's not going to be
given a title
and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
what what
first of all i i don't believe this
woman as pierce morgan said
uh you know he wouldn't believe her if
she was
reading him her like the menu at
breakfast in the morning or something
right something to that effect
um so i don't i don't i'm not saying it
didn't happen i'm just saying i have
there's no reason to believe
anything that this woman says but let's
say something like this did happen
was the conversation you know
that boy you know megan because you are
slightly dark-skinned like very very
slightly
like people wouldn't pick up on it like
my sicilian mother was much darker skin
than meghan markle much much much more
so
if that boy comes out even slightly
swarthy he we have to banish everyone
from the kingdom this is a horrible do
you think it was that conversation or do
you think it was
hmm i wonder who he's going to look like
because i don't know i'm much darker
skinned
than my wife when we were discussing
what our kid would look like oh i wonder
what it looked like will they have your
eyes will they have your nose will they
have your skin color i don't know he
actually did get my skin color
which conversation was it it seems to me
that
if the conversation were a vicious
bigoted conversation about how much
they're going to hate harry or archie
rather if he comes out
slightly dark because i guess the kid is
what he's like an eighth black or
something
that you know he that would be terrible
for the royal family don't you think
that conversation would have happened
before harry got married don't you think
that
conversation would have happened before
the royal family accepted meghan markle
before prince charles walked her down
the aisle
before the royal family bent over
backwards and did everything to welcome
this woman
did they j they just learned right right
when the kid was about to be born they
said oh my
gosh this woman is somewhat black oh my
goodness
wow we need to do something but uh no i
don't think so
i don't think that was the case at all
as for the title
king george v the grandfather of queen
elizabeth
uh declared in the early 20th century
quote the grandchildren of the sons of
any such
sovereign in the direct male line
save only the eldest living son of the
eldest son of the prince of wales
shall have and enjoy in all occasions
the style and title enjoyed
by the children of dukes of this realm
in layman's terms what that means is
that
all the little boys in the direct mail
line from the
from the king will be styled
prince in the line of succession
harry is the son of
charles but harry is not
second in line to the throne or third in
line to the throne or fourth or fifth
he's sixth now in line to the throne if
william has more
kids he'll be even further away archie
far further away than that it doesn't
just go
on like that forever this is something
that has been a long-standing
convention no evidence whatsoever that
it is racist
or bigoted but everything
in this world has to come down to race
and i think some of the revulsion that
people feel
at this absolutely sickening interview
between the markles mr and mrs markle
and oprah is this sick obsession with
race
and this failure to have gratitude for
anything that we have even if you're a
rich
famous beautiful princess or prince
head on over to dailywire.com check out
ben's show where he talks about all the
things that joe biden is doing and most
of the things that joe biden doesn't
even know that he's doing also head on
over subscribe
to the michael knowles show youtube
channel you're gonna like you can
comment you can subscribe we've got some
fun stuff coming up woke white guilt
commercials
and a new very official important tier
ranking system
for uh to use the language of the utes
how
based you are that's like
that's the cool new lingo for how
knuckle dragging
right wing you are go check it out uh
it's on the youtube channel we'll be
right back
with a lot more
it has finally happened
dr seuss as you know was canceled by his
publisher
six highly offensive cartoons what is
the offense i don't know i still can't
figure it out
canceled by his publisher in those six
books therefore you can't find the books
really anymore on amazon you can buy
them on the second hand market they're
like almost 700
apiece you can't get them on ebay
occasionally you'll still see them pop
up but ebay has said they are going to
remove
these items from the marketplace
but new york public library had said
we're not going to remove them from the
library that's good kids can still check
out the dr seuss books
from their libraries we're not we're not
having library purges yet
of children's books chicago it's a
different story chicago public
library has said that they are going to
cancel these
dr seuss books according to
chicago public library spokesman patrick
malloy officials are
deeply committed to promoting reading
material
that provides accurate and current
information
and apparently these dr seuss cartoons
they weren't
accurate you know it turns out that
people
aren't like sort of green bunny rabbit
looking things
it turns out that cats don't really wear
hats did you know that
what is what is accurate and current
information with regard to children's
books
current here is an important aspect of
it too so this spokesman says quote
it is important to recognize that what
society understands to be relevant
and or common knowledge changes over
time
and so too does the library in the needs
of the communities it serves
library staff encourage patrons of all
ages to engage critically with our
materials but materials that become
dated
or that foster inaccurate culturally
harmful stereotypes
are removed to make space for more
current comprehensive materials
that word dated i think that's the key
here
because in a very basic sense
all reading material becomes dated
over time i don't think so i mean i
think that
i i don't partake of this very left-wing
vision of culture and history that the
past
bad future good present wonderful
i think that there's much to be learned
from the past and in many ways the past
was
superior to the time we're living in now
some ways it's not in some ways it is
by the logic of this left winger at the
chicago library
they're going to get rid of all the
books in the library because they're all
dated to some degree goodness gracious
the bible is dated in some ways
when are we going to get rid of all that
too
that the very purpose of a library is to
preserve these works of art literature
and history
keep them in a nice special place where
you can go and access that knowledge
even without money go in you can check
it out
and you can preserve that culture
throughout the ages
and what the spokesman for the chicago
library is saying is
now we don't want those old ages get rid
of that stuff might as well torch
the library i don't think i'm being
hyperbolic
because it it isn't just about dr seuss
dr
seuss is this kind of silly example of
it but this has been going on for a long
time
and it's getting much much worse the
library further
added quote that they want to ensure
that the materials we circulate
are responsive to the communities we
serve
the purpose of a library is not
to be responsive to the communities we
serve
the purpose of a that that's the purpose
of a fast food restaurant
fast food restaurant is supposed to
cater to the appetites
of the customer
movie theaters same thing
libraries are different the purpose of a
library is to educate
to entertain to a degree to serve as a
homeless shelter if you're in los
angeles
sure primarily the purpose
is to educate and education
is not about serving the appetites and
desires
of the student education is about
instructing the student in what they
should know
and what is not worth knowing in what is
true
and what is false in what is right
and what is wrong in what is good and in
what is bad
that is an arrogant act you might say
it's an arrogant act because the people
who
curate the library are
telling you this is better than that
read this
this you don't need to read this we're
going to include in our catalog this
we're not and that's what the library is
still doing no matter what gobbledygook
they say about
we need to be responsive to community
it's not quite quite that way
there may maybe they're responding to
public pressure
but they're curating an experience and
what they're saying is that
old things are bad undermines the
premise of a library
just one more reason that people are
leaving places like chicago
according to the associated press right
now 144 cities
could be downgraded from the term
metropolitan
to micropolitan they're
being a download downgraded rather
according to the metropolitan
statistical area status
and this is because people are fleeing
the cities right now why are people
fleeing the cities
well in part because a bunch of
sociopath politicians have locked
everyone
in inside for a year so if you live in
new york i lived in new york for a very
long time
if you live in manhattan say or even
brooklyn or even a little further out
you live in a very small little pod my
first apartment after college in
manhattan
i was sharing it with two other guys my
bedroom was 70
square feet 7-0
we couldn't get the bed in through the
door we actually had to build a sort of
fake wall that didn't even go all the
way up to the ceiling
after we put the bed in and it didn't
have any windows
and i spent a lot of money on that
apartment i said it's like something
like 1100
a month maybe more you do that you live
in a little shoe box in the cities
because
your living room is the city itself you
go to the bars you go to the restaurants
you go to the museums if you're in new
york you go to central park
you go to beer gardens right you'd go to
the theater what
the whole city is your playground if all
that's shut down there is
zero reason to pay those exorbitant
prices to live in a little matchbox in
the city
so people are moving out this
is great news
excellent news part of the reason
they're doing it too is you know
obviously people are commuting
on their computers now right it's zoom
meetings can't do it for every job but a
lot of jobs and especially
jobs of yuppies who are living in
manhattan you can telecommute so people
are leaving
this is great news for conservatives we
should celebrate it there's very rarely
great news for conservatives in our news
cycle so we should take the win when we
can
urbanization leads to liberalism
and progressivism it just happens it's
always the way that happens
when cities start to go from red to blue
it's because the cities are growing
there is something about being attracted
to the cities that
makes people more left-wing we could
spend hours and hours talking about why
that is but
suffice it to say that is a an eternal
fact
with very very few exceptions throughout
history if any exceptions
when people leave the cities this is
very good news for conservatives
now one of the reasons that people
fleeing to the
moving into the cities that urbanization
is so bad for conservatives
is not just because it gives more power
centers in red states and maybe flip
states
it's also because it homogenizes the
culture so it removes localism
if you were to look at america 100 years
ago
before sort of mass urbanization you
would have seen lots of different little
cultures
it's even clearer if you look at a
country like italy where you have lots
of little cultures all over the place
but now as the cities have grown the
cities are all basically the same they
all really resemble one another quite a
lot
and the culture becomes much more
standardized very bad for localism
subsidiary federalism
conservative governance
the fear here is that as libs leave the
cities and move into the suburbs and
exurbs and
out into the country that this is
actually going to be bad because they're
going to turn
our nice conservative places blue
i'm not that worried about that i'm much
happier
removing some of the power of the cities
dispersing
those libs throughout the countryside
and the suburbs and the excerpts if they
really do that
because while it might cost us a couple
of elections for city council or
i guess town council or town supervisor
or something
what that will do the benefit of that i
think will outweigh the negative which
is
it will force libs to be around
conservatives when you're in the city
you don't really need to be around
conservatives when you're in the country
or even the suburbs you do
and you have to realize then that what
you were told on cnn and msnbc in the
new york times
is not true you're gonna have to realize
because you're just gonna see it with
your neighbors
that the trump supporters are not nazis
they're not literally hitler you have
been lied to
you're gonna get along with people you
have to
get back together again if you want to
have a functioning country
if everyone's just going to go to their
own little corners and we're all going
to live in our own little pods and our
sort of semi-virtual realities with very
little in common then you don't have
much of a country
we need to get together again not just
by moving
moving out into more spacious
territories but also by meeting up
getting together having thanksgiving
having christmas celebrating birthdays
we haven't been allowed to do that by
the psychos in the cdc
and the public health experts and the
politicians for a year now though good
news from the cdc
a year into two weeks to slow the spread
they're going to let us see one another
again in very limited circumstances
cdc recommends that fully vaccinated
people can visit with other
fully vaccinated people in small
gatherings indoors
without wearing masks or physical
distancing so what does this mean
if you and a friend or you and a family
member are both vaccinated
you can have dinner together wearing
masks without distancing
you can visit your grandparents if you
have been vaccinated and they have been
too i know that i can see my friends
i know that i can go meet up with people
at their houses
or in public i know that i can see my
relatives
because i've been doing that for a year
because i've been ignoring all of you
awful tyrants all of you awful
lab coat dictators who have been
changing your guidance day by day
changing your reasoning day by day but
somehow the
the rules always seem to stay the same
or get worse
i know i can do all that i'm pleased
that you the rest of the people who have
been following you
very foolishly will now be told that but
we've known this for a very long time i
uh
strongly recommend that you take
advantage of this opportunity
if you have not gone and seen your
friends and relatives you absolutely
should go do it but
the cdc is not going to let go of all
the power yet see they're saying well if
it's a
if it's a vaccinated person seeing
someone who is unvaccinated who knows
someone who's this then you can't you've
got to
forget about it forget about it i think
they know that they're losing power
and i think they know that people you
just look around you and see people are
just violating it they've had enough of
this stuff
and so they're going to start to let up
on it just ignore these people
there is no re they have just been wrong
and wrong and wrong again
they have the public health expert
apparatus
has in some cases been outright
dishonest and
i just don't see any reason to to pay
any attention to them
whatsoever you've got to get back
together it is disordered
to muzzle yourself in public to not be
able to see your fellow citizens
smiling faces it is disordered
not to go see your friends and relatives
not to gather together man is a social
animal
and there are more important things in
life
than a a cough if you're
in an extraordinary extraordinarily
at-risk
group you know be prudent prudence is a
virtue
but that's not really what i notice most
people i know who are sort of up there
in age
they're the least likely people to wear
their masks because they know better
they're the least likely people to
refuse to see anybody
the people i notice doing this are all
these perfectly healthy millennials
who have totally warped sense
of themselves in the world it's the sort
of meghan markle generation
they don't they've just totally
gone gone upside down come together
everybody i beg you
we need to appropriate cultures we need
to appropriate you're not allowed to
appropriate culture but we do need to
get together and chris cuomo just got in
trouble
for cultural appropriation because chris
cuomo was on
tv talking to his friend don lemo as dr
carlson calls him
and chris cuomo made the claim that he's
black
on the inside take a listen just looking
out of the window
watching the asphalt grow
again how it all looks how do you know
the words
the good times you know i'm black on the
inside so
time time you need a baby so
florida chris cuomo very in trouble for
this shocking
microaggression macro aggression you can
tell don lemon doesn't seem to care
about it
uh i hate i'm not going to defend chris
cuomo but in this particular moment i
guess i have to
you can't at once tell people be less
white and then also tell them don't
appropriate any cultures
good times is a great tv show it's not
the greatest black sitcom of the era
that award would go to the jeffersons
but there's actually an important lesson
to take out of this stupid bantering
between the two of them
which is you've got to get together talk
to one another see one another take the
stupid mask off it so you can actually
communicate with one another
enjoy one another's cultures not be so
prideful not be so arrogant not be so
demanding not be so
trigger-happy to be offended all the
time then you're gonna have a country
i'm not even this isn't just some
rousing sort of feel good come on we all
gotta get together i'm just saying
if you if you do that you have a country
if you don't do that you don't have a
country
which way will the country go
there is some very good news on the
political front
for we here on the right in the
republican party
david bosse chairman of the rnc debate
commission
was just speaking with breitbart at
cpac and he did something or he
committed to do something
that a lot of us on the right have been
begging the republican party to do for
years and years and years which is
for years now we know that the
mainstream media are the opposition
party we know that the mainstream media
so-called mainstream media the
establishment media legacy media
whatever you want to call them they
are democrats they work for the
democrats they push the democrats
narratives there is
no distinction really to be made between
the media and the democrats
and yet we allow those mainstream media
to run our presidential debates
the left doesn't do that the left
doesn't go to daily wire and say hey
daily wire we want you to moderate the
democratic presidential debate they
don't know that they go to their guys
and yet for some reason republicans go
to their guys too well
david bossie now saying no more
so what we're doing is we're going to
make sure
that the presidential debates uh are
fair
are are on the networks that are not
going to beat us up
um uh and and therefore uh
look we're not going to be having any of
the cnn and msnbc's of the world
so we're going to do a great job and i
think that the the party's going to be
better off for it
the party will be much much better off
for that
i'm not saying that nbc
or some left-wing outlet can't moderate
an actual presidential debate
between the democrats democratic nominee
and the republican nominee
probably you're going to have to do that
at least do one of the debates if we
ever have more debates
but why would you let the opposition
moderate your
own party's primary campaigns doesn't
make any sense at all glad to see that
after years and years and decades and
decades the republicans are waking up to
this
speaking of cuomo's speaking a little
earlier of chris cuomo
we have to turn from fredo to michael
from chris to andrew cuomo
andrew cuomo is under fire the
democratic leaders in his state are
calling on him to resign
cuomo says impeach me
this according to the associated press
in a brief phone conversation sunday
prior to the press conference cuomo told
new york state senate majority leader
andrea stewart cousins
that he would not quit and they would
have to impeach him if they want him out
of office
i love this oh do i love this
one i admire andrew cuomo
not general generally speaking i think
he's a degenerate and a derelict but
but i admire his political courage here
because what cuomo is seeing he's
looking around he's saying okay
you opportunist dems you people
are getting rid of me now because of
some ginned up contrived
sex thing where no one's even alleging
that any of us had any sex
you're just kind of it's just some very
vague me too
political thing when we all know
that you're gonna go after me for the
handling of covid and for the cover-up
of kovid
but you don't want to admit that that's
why you're going after me because that's
going to make all of you look bad
well okay if you really want me out
impeach me what are you going to impeach
me for are you going to impeach me for
giving an italian sausage and pepper
sandwich to a reporter
which is actually one of the complaints
that
democrats are making here that one time
andrew cuomo
was at some political event and a
reporter was hungry and he gave her a
sausage and pepper sandwich
and made jokes about eating the sandwich
are you going to impeach me for that
or are you going to impeach me for
killing thousands of elderly new yorkers
and covering it up a crime that
implicates
a lot of you people too what are you
gonna do
impeach me i love it i totally i think
that is a great
one good for him for standing up for his
career i don't like his political
career but good for him for standing up
for it and the other reason i love it is
the
the schadenfreude here because now i've
got to watch all these democrats in new
york squirm
because they don't want to go after him
for that does he survive it's hard to
see how he survives i mean he's really
really under fire right now but if
anybody can do it it's andrew cuomo you
shouldn't count that guy out
too soon he's clearly going to exercise
all of his options
until he can do so no more speaking of
people running for president
we have some potential uh presidential
nominees in 2024 and the question is who
are they going to run against
are they going to run against joe biden
are they going to run against kamala
harris well joe biden was recently
giving a press conference and during
that press conference
he forgot the name of the pentagon
his secretary of defense and then had to
be told where to go
after he left the podium i want to thank
you both and i want to thank
the the uh former general i keep calling
him general
my my uh the guy who runs that outfit
over there
uh i want to make sure we thank the
secretary
for all he's done to try to implement
what we just talked about
and for recommending these two women for
promotion
thank you all may god bless you all and
may god protect our troops
oh all right now in turns basis kamala
faces okay one of the
service women and then huh where do i
turns he's got his back to the reporters
where do i huh wait a minute
where's that guy what's that guy this
the general he's not a general i know is
he's a
is he a lieutenant no he's not he's more
than it was his secretary secretary
that's right secretary of what
anyway thank you
somebody tells me that guy is not going
to be the nominee in 2024.
we are like two months
into his first not even not even like a
less than a month and a half into his
first year in office and the guy can't
remember the name of his cabinet
secretaries
so what does this mean for 2024
is it kamala maybe who runs against
kamala lots of
people mike pompeo intimating that he
might be interested
in running uh ron desantis seems poised
to run
lots uh my colleague here candace owens
has said she might run for president
lots of other lots of other
candidates about to throw their hats in
the ring we might be
not not at the beginning of the new
biden arrow we might we might be at the
end of something here and what what
comes next
i suppose it's up to us i hope it's up
to us i hope it's not too late for us to
still have a say in our government i'm
michael moses the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 on the matt welsh show we talk
about the things that matter real issues
that affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show